A qué se refieren estos saberes
ancestrales Cómo es que unos niños tan
pequeños pueden sobrevivir
un saludo de armonía de parte de la
guardia indígena
nacional a todos ustedes
muy importante esta misión de búsqueda
de los niños y creo que un elemento
fundamental fue el conocimiento
ancestral el saber ancestral
los saberes ancestrales para las
comunidades son fundamentales en su
desarrollo de la vida en su desarrollo
de sus pensamientos en el desarrollo de
la misma vida en los territorios es por
eso que este pensamiento estos saberes
estos conocimientos ancestrales Se
volvieron herramienta fundamental para
la búsqueda de estos cuatro niños en
perdidos en esta selva si no conocemos
la selvas si no sabemos sobre la selva
es imposible movernos en la selva el
conocimiento ancestral la sabiduría
ancestral los saberes la orientación de
los abuelos la orientación de los
mayores nos permitió que hoy
encontráramos a los niños tanto para
ellos como para los que buscábamos
es muy importante ese saber ancestral
para las comunidades es muy importante y
ese saber ancestral queremos reflejarlo
porque nos da a conocer los que somos
los pueblos y y nos da a conocer como
como elemento fundamental para tenerlo
en cuenta en las proyecciones Y en este
trabajo para defender la vida es por eso
que fue clave el saber ancestral en la
búsqueda de estos cuatro menores algo
que llamó la atención fue la unión entre
los indígenas y el ejército para esta
operación de búsqueda de una unidad que
se podría considerar sin precedentes
como ocurrió
importante también fue la alianza que
logramos hacer entre el ejército
y las y el movimiento indígena y sus
guardias indígenas creo que esta Alianza
es fue fundamental en el ejercicio de
poder
mantenernos con esperanza
compartíamos con el ejército
compartíamos comida compartimos
sabiduría ancestral y compartimos
conocimiento tecnológico creo que es muy
importante y fue de mucha importancia el
combinar estas dos sabidurías estos dos
conocimientos
Porque mientras unos nos guiamos con GPS
nos guiamos con con las ayudas también
tecnológicas y hacía perifoneos repartía
comida en la selva con los helicópteros
otros caminábamos en la selva bajo la
protección de los Espíritus de los
mayores y bajo la capacidad organizativa
de los pueblos indígenas
esta tos
formas de protección estas dos formas de
vida
permitieron que encontráramos la vida es
por eso que la alianza entre las fuerzas
militares y este plan Esperanza entre
fuerzas militares y y guardias indígenas
dio resultados y el resultado fue
encontrar los niños
encontrarlos sanos y salvos con
situaciones de desnutrición pero
poderlos encontrar es muy importante
podernos encontrar para compartir
sabidurías compartir conocimientos y
para mandar un mensaje de unidad y de
paz a Colombia creo que en estos
momentos de mucha incertidumbre en
Colombia es de suma importancia estos
estas alianzas estos reconocimientos
este apoyo en conjunto fue muy
estratégico esta Alianza entre las
fuerzas militares y la guardia indígena
para encontrar los niños y Cuál es la
situación con las disidencias de las
Farc en la zona está el padre está la
familia de los menores en peligro
hay muchas situaciones difíciles en los
pueblos indígenas que vivimos
los indígenas todo todo el tiempo y son
las amenazas en cuanto a la información
que se tiene sobre las amenazas al padre
de los niños creo que es una amenaza que
siempre han vivido los pueblos indígenas
y por eso el desplazamiento por eso
tener que salir de los territorios es
por eso que yo pido la protección
especial para este padre que pues que se
encuentra con sus hijos y que no se lo
vayan a arrebatar de los brazos porque
debe continuar la vida la mamá de ellos
murió la madre de ayer se fue y creo que
hay una responsabilidad del padre para
acompañar y debe estar en armonía es por
eso que es muy importante dar todo el
acompañamiento desde las diferentes
instituciones a la familia para que este
padre pueda llevar continuar su vida
desde los principios de los pueblos
indígenas pero también con el apoyo de
todos creo que es lo mejor lo más bonito
que podemos dar para seguir que continúe
la vida de estos cuatro niños Así que yo
hago un llamado al gobierno nacional
para que estos este padre que está
amenazado se pueda proteger y a los
niños para que pueda continuar la vida
y la esperanza